did you know that ancient Mesopotamia
like thousands of years ago
revolutionized agriculture that's right
around 3,000 BCE the Sumerians developed
Advanced plows and irrigation systems
that transformed farming the plow a
crucial invention allowed them to till
the soil more efficiently increasing
crop yields their sophisticated
irrigation systems including canals and
diyes enabled them to control water flow
from the Tigris and Euphrates rivers
ensuring a stable water supply for their
C s these Innovations supported the
growth of their civilization and
influenced agricultural practices for
Millennia so tell me